t mais auparavant un rapide coup d'oeil
aux effets d'halloween avec ces quelques
images commentées par myriam alma voici
le royaume terrifiant d'halloween
âmes sensibles s'abstenir une fête
directement importée des états unis là
bas chaque 31 octobre au soir
les enfants se déguisent en monstres et
cie aux portes pour quémander des
bonbons
cette année la frénésie halloween
déferle sur l'hexagone comme ici porte
maillot à paris où des milliers de
citrouilles ont envahi les arbres et la
pelouse
tous les prétextes sont bons pour mettre
en scène le légume de cendrillon les
fabricants de masques français ont même
trouvé une origine celtique à la fête
nos ancêtres célébrer paraît-il le
retour de la saison froide autour d'un
avait devenu citrouilles en franchissant
l'atlantique cette année on devrait
battre tous les records 100 millions de
chiffre d'affaires sont attendus tout le
monde s'y met grandes surfaces commerce
avec par exemple cet oeil à 5 francs ou
ce déguisement à 300 francs + et l'est
plus les enfants adorent halloween c'est
une fête rentable les entreprises ont
bien compris elle s'engouffre elle aussi
dans la brèche à grand renfort de
publicité même le marché de rungis est
sensible aux phénomènes le cours de la
citrouille est monté de 15% ces derniers
jours